Ember gets a speed
boost with Glimmer,
and we explore new
forms of storytelling
for the collective intelligence.
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is LazyWeb.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ember's new rendering engine
Glimmer is now in Canary.
Inspired by React's
Virtual DOM, Ember
attempts to improve upon
things by only dipping bindings
instead of the entire DOM.
According to the team,
this dramatically
improves performance on
benchmarks like DBMonster.
You can follow this guide to
learn more about migrating
to Glimmer in Ember 2.0.
Let's explore storytelling for
the collective intelligence.
Senongo Akpem, creator of
the Pixel Fable project,
describes the process of
creating nonlinear stories
utilizing modern technology.
He codifies and demonstrates
several examples,
including extra narratives like
an "An Idea Lives On," parallel
narratives featured in "Project
Moon," and micronarratives
illustrated by his own
site "Lost Nigeria."
Do websites need a diet?
Scott Jehl tweets that
the average web page now
weighs over 2 megabytes with
62% of that coming from images.
Projects like "What
Does My Site Cost"
demonstrate this can translate
to serious money for users.
New standards like
picture and source set
can help combat the problem,
but it's up to developers
to start leveraging them.
Firefox 38 hits
stable this week,
and with it comes a
number of improvements.
Best highlighted on
the Mozilla hacks blog,
the new release contains support
for both picture and image
source set, web
sockets in Web Workers,
BroadcastChannel that post
messages to all open tabs,
and some bonus
Dev Tools goodies.
You can check out the developer
release notes over on MDN.
Chrome on Android now
has a Dev channel.
Detailed on the Chromium
blog, the new Dev channel
allows developers
to test their site
using an early version of
Chrome to find bugs and try out
cutting edge features.
The new channel is updated
at least every week
and is already available
on the Google Play Store.
Programmatic Copy and
Paste is coming to Firefox.
A recent intent to
implement and ship thread
indicates that Firefox will
add support for Copy and Paste
via the exec command method
in response to user action.
Similar behavior is already
supported in Chrome 43,
IE10, and Opera 29.
To learn more about
Copy and Paste,
you can check out this
article on HTML5 Rocks.
That's it for this week, folks.
Take a deep breath,
enjoy the visuals,
and to all you LazyWebbers out
there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]